Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Salut les gens, j'espère que vous allez bien. Ravi de vous retrouver une fois de plus.
Pour une fois, j'ai respecté mes engagements. Je suis très content de livrer cet épisode seulement deux semaines après le dernier.
Vous avez été nombreux à apprécier mon entretien avec Zakaria Katabi. Merci pour vos retours. Ça fait toujours énormément plaisir.
De mon côté, j'ai été vacciné la semaine dernière. J'ai eu la chance de remplacer indécemment et j'ai pu recevoir ma première dose du vaccin Pfizer.
Tout doucement, on s'approche de la fin de cette pandémie et ça, c'est plutôt cool. Et à propos de pandémie, on va en parler à nouveau et plus précisément des théories du complot qui ont fleuri ces quinze derniers mois.
J'ai eu le plaisir de me rendre chez Emmanuelle Danblon, qui travaille depuis plus de dix ans sur la rhétorique complotiste à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles.
Comment peut-on reconnaître un discours complotiste ? Pourquoi y en a-t-il tellement de nos jours ? Quels outils pour lutter contre ces tendances ?
Ensemble, on a pu aborder toutes ces questions et bien plus encore. Juste une précision avant de se lancer, on jargonne un petit peu dans l'épisode, on essaye de définir les termes employés à chaque fois.
Donc si jamais vous êtes distrait et que vous ne saisissez pas ce que signifient les mots comme épidictique ou apodictique, n'hésitez pas à revenir un peu en arrière.
Bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir de recevoir Emmanuelle Danblon. Emmanuelle bonjour.
Bonjour.
Emmanuelle Danblon, vous êtes professeure à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles, à la Faculté des Lettres. Vous enseignez la rhétorique, les théories de l'argumentation et l'histoire des idées linguistiques.
Et vous travaillez au sein du groupe de recherche en rhétorique et en argumentation linguistique, donc le fameux GRAL. J'aime beaucoup cet acronyme.
Et vous êtes régulièrement dans le jury des concours d'éloquence Eloquentia. Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose ?
Non, c'est tout à fait parfait.
Mais formidable.
Merci beaucoup.
Je suis ravi.
Belle présentation.
Alors, j'avais eu le plaisir de recevoir Olivier Klein il y a exactement un an pour parler de conspirationnisme, donc plutôt à travers le prisme de la psychologie sociale, puisque c'est son domaine.
La question est toujours et plus que jamais sur la table. Et donc on va parler ensemble dans quelques instants
des discours complotistes, donc vus à travers le prisme, cette fois, plutôt de l'analyse de discours, de la rhétorique, puisque ce sont vos spécialités, vos domaines.
Mais peut-être avant de se plonger au cœur du sujet, parlons un peu de vous. Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à travailler en linguistique ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait que vous, en tant que personne, vous êtes attirée par les questions, voilà, de rhétorique, d'analyse de discours et ainsi de suite ?
Ah mais c'est une très gentille question parce qu'elle me permet de
raconter un souvenir d'enfance, une anecdote qui peut-être résume un peu ma passion pour la linguistique qui est, je vais pas dire de naissance parce que ce serait exagéré, mais depuis toute petite.
Et cette anecdote, c'est que j'avais une nounou portugaise
et je devais avoir quatre ou cinq ans, donc j'avais pas encore appris à lire et à écrire, mais je m'étais inventé une petite théorie personnelle de la traduction, que j'ai soumise à ma nounou portugaise que j'appelais Joujou.
Et cette théorie était la suivante : c'est que puisque le A est rouge en français, il devait peut-être être vert en portugais.
Et puis Joujou m'a dit : « Mais non, ma chérie, le A n'est pas rouge en français et donc encore moins vert en portugais.
Tu es très gentille, mais tu es encore trop petite, tu dis n'importe quoi. » Et en fait, je me suis rendu compte à cette occasion que je faisais de la synesthésie.
Ah, formidable.
Voilà. Et donc bon, mon paradis synesthésique s'est écroulé au cours de cette conversation avec Joujou. Mais je crois que je tiens là l'origine de ma fascination pour les phénomènes linguistiques, pour
pour le lien entre le sens et les sons et de proche en proche pour les mécanismes de persuasion et d'argumentation.
A priori, l'échange linguistique, le dialogue, la conversation, c'est plutôt quelque chose que je qualifierais d'intuitif pour la plupart des gens.
Quand on travaille dans la Faculté des Lettres, quand on analyse les discours, quand on va chercher les formules rhétoriques, etc., on part, on quitte largement l'intuitif et on part dans l'intellect, dans le réfléchi.
Est-ce que vous êtes ce genre de personne ?
Alors, au fond, je dirais que je suis le résultat d'un paradoxe.
OK.
Parce que je suis une grande intuitive.
Mais que j'ai toujours eu l'intuition que je devais au maximum rationaliser tout ça pour ne pas m'envoler, pour que ça ne parte pas dans tous les sens.
Et au fond, ce paradoxe dont je vous parle, je dirais que ça résume le paradoxe de la rhétorique. C'est-à-dire qu'on doit,
on nous dit toujours que pour qu'une pensée soit bien formée, bien exprimée, bien expliquée, il faut qu'elle soit absolument valide, avec des raisonnements,
extrêmement bien structurés.
Et au fond, ce qui compte en rhétorique, c'est la persuasion. Et la persuasion, elle se donne toujours comme de l'évidence et donc comme le contraire de quelque chose qui est bien structuré.
Et donc, en fait, la rhétorique, c'est de l'intuition bien ordonnée.
Alors, c'est formidable parce qu'il y a déjà beaucoup de choses dans votre réponse. Je pense qu'à plusieurs reprises, on va toucher à des concepts très spécifiques à la rhétorique et à l'analyse de discours.
Déjà, la première chose qui me saute aux yeux dans votre réponse, c'est qu'on va peut-être préciser : persuader, convaincre, est-ce que c'est la même chose ?
Ah, alors y a des océans de littérature sur la différence entre persuader et convaincre. Et les chercheurs ne sont pas d'accord entre eux.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que l'idée qu'on s'en fait dans le langage courant, c'est que la conviction est plus rationnelle, plus argumentée que la persuasion qui serait, je dirais, plus intuitive et plus
plus spontanément émotionnelle.
Et en même temps, vous avez l'expression typique qu'on utilise dans les jurys d'assises, par exemple, où on parle d'intime conviction.
Mmm-hmm.
Ce qui paraît tout à fait paradoxal, voire contradictoire, voire ce qu'on appelle un oxymore, hein. Cette figure qui met ensemble deux éléments incompatibles.
Et donc voilà, puisqu'il y a deux mots, c'est qu'il y a deux concepts, mais tracer une frontière nette entre ces deux concepts, c'est pas facile du tout.
OK. Je pensais que vous alliez me répondre que vous étiez plutôt dans le camp des personnes qui pensent que ce n'est pas la même chose.
Est-ce que vous, personnellement, est-ce que vous avez une conviction ? Parce que vous m'expliquiez qu'il y avait énormément de littérature à ce sujet et que les chercheurs se disputaient.
Est-ce que vous, vous avez une conviction par rapport à ça ?
Oui, moi, ma conviction, c'est que l'héritage de la modernité nous a coupé de nos intuitions et nous a convaincus qu'il fallait se méfier de nos émotions.
Et du coup, dans cette vision des choses, il y a vraiment une séparation nette entre convaincre et persuader.
Quelque part, convaincre, c'est bien parce que c'est rationnel. Persuader, c'est pas bien parce que c'est émotionnel. Et je crois que nous devons réconcilier les deux.
Je crois que les deux aspects existent, mais qu'être équilibré, c'est être capable de faire dialoguer conviction et persuasion.
Mmm-hmm. Et il y a d'ailleurs, je crois, un mythe de l'Antiquité qui illustre bien ça, mais vous le connaissez mieux que moi, donc je vais vous laisser le raconter. C'est le fameux...
Mythe de Phryné.
Exactement.
Je vais vous le raconter parce que c'est une très jolie histoire qui, effectivement, incarne ça. Donc Phryné est une courtisane, et elle est accusée d'impiété.
Elle se rend au tribunal et elle est défendue par son avocat qui s'appelle Hypéride. Dans certaines versions du mythe, on dit que c'est aussi son amant.
Enfin, peu importe. En tout cas, ce qui est sûr, c'est qu'elle est courtisane, et très belle. Et Hypéride argumente, argumente, argumente devant les juges qui s'ennuient, qui dorment à moitié, qui n'écoutent absolument pas.
Et à court d'arguments, à un moment, il arrache la tunique de Phryné, découvrant ainsi devant les juges sa splendide nudité.
Et, comme un seul homme, si j'ose dire, ils décident d'acquitter Phryné.
Alors, il y a un épilogue au mythe, c'est qu'après cette scène extrêmement
émotionnellement forte, ils se sont réunis, ils se sont très fort inquiétés de ce qui leur est arrivé, de ce qui s'est passé et ont exigé depuis ce moment-là que les
les accusés n'apparaissent plus dans le prétoire.
Et donc ce mythe, effectivement, résume
cette concurrence entre conviction, persuasion, puisque dans un premier temps, Hypéride argumente et donc avance une série de faits rationnels, et de bonnes raisons qui devraient,
par la magie de l'inférence, du raisonnement, du syllogisme, arriver à la conclusion qu'il faut acquitter Phryné.
Et en gros, ça fonctionne pas du tout.
Et du coup, c'est le geste qui, d'une certaine façon, résume tout ce que,
tout ce que vous avez dans la force d'un témoignage, et ce geste qui dévoile la nudité de Phryné, qui, d'une certaine façon, magiquement, illustrerait son innocence.
Ce qui est évidemment, si vous essayez de mettre ça dans une loi, c'est non seulement irrationnel, mais scandaleux.
Les gens qui sont beaux sont généralement innocents. C'est-- enfin non seulement c'est faux, mais en plus, c'est très très grave.
Mmm-hmm.
Voilà. Et donc mon idée, c'est qu'il faudrait que les juges de Phryné se réconcilient avec la part d'intime conviction qui peut-être
les a véritablement fait sentir que Phryné était innocente, et en plus belle, tant mieux pour elle, mais c'est pas ça le point au fond.
Oui, mais donc leur intime conviction qui vient du fait qu'elle était belle. Donc, est-ce que c'est vraiment à défendre ?
Alors, évidemment, là, on entre dans un sujet tout à fait tabou, mais ça me permet de vous raconter une nouvelle anecdote.
Oui, allez-y.
Ce qui est tout à fait tabou, c'est qu'au fond, c'est le délit de sale gueule, hein, pour le dire simplement. Et nous avons des intuitions de délit de sale gueule.
Nous utilisons des expressions, disant : « Je le sens pas celui-là, je la sens pas celle-là », etc. Et donc ces fameuses intuitions des juges de Phryné, nous les avons.
Le problème que nous avons, c'est qu'est-ce que nous devons en faire ? Une chose est de se dire : il faut s'en méfier toujours parce que c'est toujours faux.
Une autre chose est de se dire : c'est parfois vrai, puis il y a des gens qui sont plus intuitifs que d'autres. Mais en même temps, si on a inventé
la science moderne, le droit moderne, etc., c'est pour contenir et mettre ces fameuses intuitions à l'épreuve des faits, à l'épreuve de la réfutation, etc.
Mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut les jeter à la poubelle immédiatement. J'en viens à mon anecdote parce que peut-être que c'est le moment d'introduire
la notion rhétorique d'épidictique, c'est-à-dire ces fameux discours qui sont pas du tout argumentés et qui donc ne visent pas du tout
disons la conviction justifiée et argumentée, mais qui vise ces fameuses intuitions et émotions collectives.
Et donc ce sont de grands poèmes politiques que vous allez trouver principalement dans les éloges funèbres. Et mais aussi dans les blâmes.
Par exemple, après un attentat, le chef de l'État doit faire un blâme et il va utiliser des formules un peu stéréotypées, le terrorisme a lâchement frappé, enfin y a beaucoup d'idées de lâcheté.
Et puis y a aussi beaucoup de termes esthétiquement connotés.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc, j'en viens finalement à mon anecdote.
On va revenir un peu plus tard, je pense, sur le genre de l'épidictique. Mais donc l'anecdote, oui.
L'anecdote, oui, c'est ça, parce que ça fait un lien. Si vous voulez, c'est Phryné à l'envers.
L'autre jour, y a déjà quelque temps, une discussion entre amis se déroule, et quelqu'un critique la coiffure d'une amie commune en disant : « Écoute, ça va pas du tout.
Tu vois bien qu'il y a un vrai problème caractériel. T'as vu comment elle se coiffe. » Et là-dessus, petite polémique, mais enfin, on juge pas les gens sur leur physique ni sur le choix de leur coiffure, etc.
Et là, j'en profite pour leur expliquer comment j'explique à mes étudiants comment faire un bon blâme. Et comment faire un bon blâme, c'est ça.
C'est-à-dire, c'est prendre un trait physique, la personne n'en peut strictement rien. Vous allez me dire : « La coiffure, ça se discute encore, elle pourrait changer de coiffeur », etc.
Mais bon. C'est en fait associer un trait physique à un trait moral.
Oui.
Regarde comment elle est coiffée, elle pourra jamais faire la tâche qu'on lui demande. Et si vous comprenez ça, vous comprenez à peu près tout le genre épidictique.
Et donc, dans le mythe de Phryné, y a quelque chose de ça. Et ce quelque chose, il est très archaïque, c'est-à-dire qu'on associe sa beauté à son innocence.
Et qu'on le veuille ou non, nous avons ça quelque part au fond de nous. La question, c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ?
Oui.
Est-ce qu'on le jette à la poubelle ou est-ce qu'on le met comme ça dans la science et dans le droit ? Bah évidemment, la vérité, je dirais, est entre les deux.
C'est-à-dire, il faut récupérer quelque chose de nos intuitions et il faut mettre le paquet pour les rationaliser au maximum.
Formidable. On va y revenir, comme je le disais un peu plus tard, puisqu'il est question d'analyser le complotisme à travers ces outils-là.
Avant d'en arriver là, la rhétorique, c'est une discipline qui demande énormément de pratique, évidemment, avant d'arriver à quelque chose de décent.
Tout le monde ne devient pas Cicéron du jour au lendemain. Vous avez clairement beaucoup plus d'expérience que moi à ce sujet.
Donc la question que je voulais vous poser, c'est : est-ce que vous gardez en permanence vos lunettes de linguiste, d'analyse de discours ?
Concrètement, quand vous allumez votre radio, votre télé et que vous entendez
nos politiciens habituels faire des argumentations, faire des discours politiques, est-ce que vous vous amusez spontanément à déconstruire leurs argumentations, à chercher les figures rhétoriques ?
C'est une question, au fond, que je ne m'étais jamais posée. Et je crois, pour être tout à fait honnête, que c'est devenu un peu une seconde nature.
OK. Intuitivement, donc.
Intuitivement. C'est-à-dire, je cherche pas du tout à le faire, mais oui, c'est devenu une seconde nature et je m'amuse, je dirais, des succès et des échecs rhétoriques de ce que je peux entendre autour de moi. Oui, certainement.
OK, très bien. Et donc, sur base de cette question-là, plus généralement, est-ce que selon vous, il y a eu des évolutions notables ces vingt dernières années dans la rhétorique, dans la forme des discours de nos politiciens ?
Alors, vous dites ces vingt dernières années,
Oui, j'ai pris ce chiffre au pif, je le confesse.
C'est vrai ?
Oui.
Parce qu'au fond,
Bah c'est vrai que 2001, le 11 septembre, effectivement.
C'est exactement ce que j'allais dire. C'est que si vous l'avez choisi au pif, c'est... y a pas de hasard, hein, comme disait l'autre, y a que des rendez-vous.
Et bien entendu que nous sommes entrés dans l'ère conspirationniste.
D'accord.
Ça, c'est certain.
Même dans la bouche de nos politiciens, alors ?
Dans la bouche de nos politiciens, par effet miroir.
D'accord.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ont conscience du fait qu'il y a un degré de défiance et des théories alternatives ou des discours alternatifs qui sont toujours potentiellement présents.
Et chaque orateur a en tête l'auditoire auquel il s'adresse. Et je crois que nos politiciens,
prenons le cas de la campagne de vaccination qui nous occupe en ce moment, eh bien, on sent que dans les discours, y a l'intention de rassurer et de lutter
contre une défiance qui s'incarne ou qui se manifeste dans les théories du complot. Donc oui.
Mmm-hmm. Donc, par incidence et indirectement, y a une répercussion sur la façon dont les politiciens s'adressent aux gens.
Oui, et peut-être aussi une deuxième chose qui a peut-être 20 ans ou un peu plus, c'est qu'il y a l'idée
qu'il faut persuader, qu'il faut emporter l'adhésion et que ça n'est pas du tout évident et qu'ils vont manifestement se former
chez des praticiens de la communication qui, à mes yeux, ont un principal défaut, c'est qu'ils donnent des trucs-
Mmm-hmm
...des recettes et qu'ils ne forment pas avec des outils qui permettent de trouver sa propre recette comme un grand chef cuisinier.
Oui. Donc concrètement, une politicienne va apparaître sur un plateau de BFMTV, on va l'attaquer, on va la contredire. Et elle va sortir des formules bateaux du style : « Ah, je pense que notre pays est une chance »-
Exactement. Et on sent qu'elle l'a sorti, enfin qu'elle a-
Oui.
...des formules à sortir et qu'elle la sort.
C'est ça, voilà.
Et ça fait un peu l'effet inverse malheureusement, je pense.
Mh. C'est-- nous sommes d'accord. Voilà, et donc on s'approche tout doucement du cœur de la question.
Le contexte, c'est évidemment aussi la crise de la démocratie. On parle de l'entrée dans une ère post-vérité.
Mh.
On en reparlera. Nos sociétés sont de plus en plus fragmentées, divisées. Alors du coup, la question, c'est : est-ce que la rhétorique peut nous aider à sortir de cette crise ?
Est-ce que c'est un outil pertinent ?
Oui, je crois que oui. Alors, évidemment, vous avez compris que je suis-
Biaisée ?
Je suis biaisée dans le sens où je suis véritablement tombée amoureuse de ma discipline, puisque comme je vous l'ai raconté tout à l'heure... ça remonte à loin dans mon enfance.
Mais oui, je crois qu'elle a véritablement une carte à jouer, et quelque chose à apporter à nos sociétés,
qui sont un petit peu déliquescentes et, comme vous le disiez, très, très divisées, et en crise de démocratie et de rationalité.
Alors y a deux volets. On peut les développer l'un ou l'autre si vous voulez, comme vous voulez. Le premier volet, c'est apprendre ce qu'est vraiment l'esprit critique au-delà d'un slogan et d'une formule.
Mh.
C'est-à-dire gagner en hauteur de vue sur les qualités et les défauts de sa propre position. Ça, c'est l'esprit critique, ce qu'on apprend en rhétorique.
Et la deuxième chose, c'est réapprendre à donner du sens collectivement à ce qui nous arrive, aux événements auxquels les sociétés sont confrontées.
Et ça, c'est plutôt le volet poético-épidictique qu'on a complètement voulu jeter à la poubelle depuis trois siècles maintenant.
Donc c'est ça votre grande conviction, c'est que dans les temps modernes, on se focalise complètement sur le rationnel, le démontrable, l'objectif et on laisse de côté l'émotionnel, donc le pathos-
Oui.
...l'éthos.
Exactement. C'est aussi vieux comme la rhétorique hein, puisque Platon, qui est le grand adversaire de la rhétorique sophistique, veut aussi que les choses soient les moins émotionnelles possible, etc.
Mais disons qu'avec l'entrée dans la modernité, la condamnation des émotions dans les discours s'est rejouée.
Et dans le collimateur, on a accusé la rhétorique, d'ailleurs qu'on a retirée de l'enseignement aussi bien en France qu'en Belgique,
en pensant que bien éduquer les citoyennes et les citoyens consistait à leur apprendre l'histoire et la philosophie-
Mh.
...et que ça suffisait largement. Et il faut aller, j'irai même un pas plus loin, c'est que la rhétorique a été associée à de la propagande et de la manipulation.
Notez que dans le langage courant, quand on dit la rhétorique du soupçon, la rhétorique de ceci, ça veut dire la manipulation.
C'est péjoratif chez nous.
Tout à fait. C'est la plupart du temps péjoratif. D'ailleurs, j'ai de bons amis qui me disent : « Mais c'est vachement intéressant ce que tu racontes, mais pourquoi tu appelles ça rhétorique ?
Pourquoi tu n'appellerais pas ça autrement ? » Et je dis : « Ben justement, parce qu'il faut la défendre de là où elle vient.
» Donc ça, je pense que c'est un élément important effectivement, de voir que nous souffrons-- nous avons cru que nous,
que la démocratie serait piégée par trop de rhétorique et, j'inverse la formulation, je pense qu'elle a été piégée par pas assez de rhétorique, par une carence en rhétorique.
Mh. Mh. Vous dites : « On a laissé tomber la rhétorique en Belgique et en France »,
mais alors si je ne dis pas de bêtises, il me semble que dans le fameux pacte pour un enseignement d'excellence qui, je crois, est censé impacter les
secondaires à partir de 2027, donc encore un peu de temps, le latin devient obligatoire.
Et justement, moi, personnellement, c'est au cours de latin que j'ai eu beaucoup de notions de rhétorique. Donc finalement, est-ce que la rhétorique est vraiment effacée du cursus pour de bon ?
Ben si d'ici 2027, elle est remise au goût du jour dans l'enseignement via le latin, moi, j'en serai tout à fait heureuse. Évidemment, je vous
parle d'avant ça, mais
en tout cas,
c'est vrai ce que vous dites, c'est que quand
j'ai l'occasion d'en parler avec des responsables de l'enseignement qui sont de plus en plus conscients qu'ils manquent cruellement de quelque chose pour former véritablement à l'esprit critique, oui.
On parlait il y a un instant du concept de post-vérité.
Mh.
Comment est-ce que vous définissez cette notion de post-vérité ?
Alors, il y a plusieurs choses à en dire, mais je crois que la première chose à en dire, c'est que, par sa structure même, elle évoque la postmodernité, c'est-à-dire quelque chose qui serait au-delà de la vérité,
et bien sûr ancrée dans une épistémologie postmoderne qui, en gros, pour simplifier très fort, aurait tendance à dire que,
qu'à peu près tout se vaut, qu'à peu près tous les discours doivent être mis au même niveau, qu'ils soient argumentés ou la-
Oui. C'est la fameuse formule : « La vérité n'appartient à personne, chacun a sa propre vérité ».
Voilà, exactement. Et donc, la post-vérité, c'est ça. Et je crois que souvent, dans les analyses, elle est confondue avec du mensonge ou de la propagande.
Mais ce que je défends, c'est que c'est beaucoup plus grave que du mensonge et de la propagande. Et c'est bien entendu ce qu'on a vu chez Trump, mais y a pas que lui, c'est que c'est une- Comment je vais dire ça ?
C'est un mépris officiel et affiché pour la vérité. C'est une position épistémologique spontanée qui dit : « La vérité, c'est un truc dépassé, c'est un truc de plouc, c'est un truc tout à fait vieux et sans aucun intérêt ».
Mmh.
Et au fond, ça me fait penser à cette prophétie de Nietzsche qui disait : « On va bientôt perdre le goût du vrai ».
La post-vérité, c'est le témoignage du fait qu'on a effectivement perdu le goût du vrai.
Oui. Et donc vous semblez dire que cette post-vérité, ça nous vient donc du postmodernisme et de quelque chose qui est très ancré dans nos cultures.
Est-ce que vous pouvez approfondir ? D'où est-ce que ça vient exactement, cette tendance à mettre de côté, ben cette vérité objective, ce factfulness, finalement, le-
Oui, c'est ça. Alors déjà, je pense qu'il faut voir qu'un phénomène contemporain ou récent n'efface pas nécessairement ce qui s'est passé avant.
Mmh-mmh.
Donc le phénomène de la post-vérité, il se nourrit aussi, bien entendu, de la bonne vieille propagande, de la propagande de guerre, du déni collectif, des négationnismes, etc.
Ça, ce sont des choses qui sont très anciennes. Et y a de ça aussi dans la post-vérité. Mais la véritable nouveauté,
je crois, c'est qu'elle témoigne du fait que la frontière entre réalité et fiction s'est totalement brouillée
et que quelque part, c'est revendiqué,
jusque dans les universités comme une position tout à fait rationnelle-
Mmh.
...ou intellectuellement acceptable.
OK.
Donc je crois que ça dit un petit peu ça.
Oui, donc ça dit ça. Ça s'illustre très bien, donc on va y revenir, mais par le conspirationnisme, donc par cette notion de, comme vous le disiez, cette frontière entre réalité et fiction qui s'amoindrit, qui s'efface.
Mais je reviens avec ma question et peut-être que vous n'avez pas de réponse et c'est une réponse tout à fait valide.
D'où est-ce que ça vient ?
Cette post-vérité ?
Oui, c'est ça. Si ce n'est pas forcément tout nouveau ces vingt dernières années, c'est en tout cas ces vingt dernières années qu'on le constate peut-être le plus.
J'espère que je ne dis pas de bêtises.
Ce qu'on dit, c'est que la post-vérité, c'est beaucoup plus récent, hein.
Oui.
Le terme est entré dans le dictionnaire d'Oxford en 2017, si je me souviens bien. Donc c'est assez récent.
Très contemporain.
Oui, voilà, exactement. Donc c'est-- Et ça, peut-être, on aura l'occasion d'en reparler, c'est qu'il y a deux générations de théories du complot.
On n'est plus du tout dans le bon vieux, si j'ose dire, complot du 11 septembre 2001.
D'accord.
Ça, on peut...
Ben donc si on revient systématiquement donc au 11 septembre 2001, qu'est-ce qui fait dans cet événement que ça déclenche une vague de complotisme, de post-vérité, de...
Alors, donc je crois qu'il faut séparer deux aspects, pour revenir à votre question qui est : d'où viendrait la post-vérité ?
Je m'étais pas posé la question comme ça, donc merci.
Mmh-mmh.
Mais une hypothèse, c'est qu'elle viendrait en remplacement
des récits épidictiques qui devraient être là pour nous aider à donner du sens à des événements invraisemblables comme,
l'a été l'attaque des tours jumelles en 2001, comme l'est aujourd'hui cette pandémie mondiale que nous traversons.
Et comme je crois qu'il faut absolument remonter à la découverte des camps de la mort en 1945. C'est-à-dire, en fait, ça fait 80 ans qu'on passe de sidération en sidération.
Et la seule chose qu'on puisse essayer de faire pour rationaliser un petit peu tout ça, ou en tout cas pour surmonter ces sidérations, c'est produire des récits collectifs qu'on va trouver dans les fonctions épidictiques.
Et donc, comme on ne fait pas ça, ben la post-vérité vient en remplacement de ça.
Mmh.
Et donc, quelque part, elle nous dit : « Je vais vous réinventer une histoire », sauf qu'elle ne se présente pas comme une histoire, elle se présente comme la vérité.
OK. Donc pour reprendre ça, y a l'idée qu'on a ces événements traumatiques. Vous donnez l'exemple des camps de concentration ou du 11 septembre.
Il y a en réponse à ça une absence de sens collectif, de direction, de : mais que se passe-t-il ? Pourquoi ? Donc voilà, de réponse au pourquoi.
Et pour répondre à ce pourquoi, on est plutôt sur du, très froidement, du factuel, du logos, du mathématique et assez peu sur, donc, des fonctions épidictiques, des fonctions poétiques.
Est-ce que j'ai bien compris ?
C'est exactement ça. Et pour aller au bout de votre proposition que je trouve très éclairante, c'est que-
Je n'ai fait que répéter ce que vous disiez.
Ah ben voilà, vous éclairez ce que je dis, c'est génial. Mais au fond, le cœur de la question, c'est : que s'est-il passé ?
Voilà, je dirais ça.
C'est ça.
C'est là-- En fait, c'est ce que vous avez dit qui m'a fait prendre conscience que le cœur de la question, c'est : que s'est-il passé ?
Et l'épidictique est là pour nous raconter une histoire collective qui nous raconte ce qui s'est passé. Et le négationnisme, à la question : que s'est-il passé ?
Répond : rien. La post-vérité, à la question : que s'est-il passé ? Répond : des faits alternatifs, comme on disait à la Maison Blanche à l'époque de Trump.
Et donc la question est de savoir si rien ou des faits alternatifs, ça appartient au réel ou à l'illusion, à la fiction, etc.
Oui. J'ai pour souvenir que lors des attentats donc de Charlie Hebdo, très rapidement, sur les réseaux sociaux, je voyais apparaître des personnes qui, mais vraiment, on est du-
Presque en temps réel.
Oui oui, en temps réel, interprétaient : « Non, mais regardez, la couleur des rétroviseurs n'est pas la même sur les deux photos, machin chouette, truc ».
Et il y avait très fort cette impression que c'était, oui, du négationnisme aussi. C'était pour dire : « Mais non, regardez, il ne s'est rien passé.
En fait, on nous ment ».
Exactement.
Et donc, oui, c'est pour s'auto-rassurer.
Tout à fait. Donc là, ce que vous soulignez, c'est ce qui, dans le conspirationnisme, relève du déni.
Mmm-hmm.
Et je pense qu'en fait, d'une certaine façon, le
conspirationnisme témoigne de presque toutes les pathologies du regard qui nous tentent tous à tout moment et qui d'ailleurs, pour certaines d'entre elles, sont tout à fait bénéfiques à certains moments.
Et donc là, il y a une part de déni qu'on connaît tous, c'est-à-dire face à un événement traumatisant, face à une mauvaise nouvelle, face à quelque chose de très difficile à encaisser.
On commence par se dire : « Mais non, c'est pas possible, c'est pas vrai, j'ai rêvé », etc. Donc, il y a une part de rationalité dans toutes, toutes, toutes ces protections du regard.
Le problème, c'est quand on s'installe dedans, et que ça remplace définitivement le réel. Oui.
Oui. Et donc, à ce moment-là, si on a fixé le problème, la solution, ce serait quoi ? De fournir des fonctions épidictiques de par nos institutions, de donner des, d'utiliser des,
des, voilà des, vous parliez de poésie, donner du sens grâce à la poésie ?
On ne comprend pas très bien quelle serait la, à quoi ressemblerait la solution ?
Pour le-- face aux théories du complot ?
Oui, par exemple.
Alors, pour moi, la solution, elle est dans la production d'histoires-
Oui.
...collectives, fictionnelles. Bah, je vais vous raconter peut-être un petit peu l'expérience que j'ai déjà en ces matières.
Alors, il y a quelques années, avec un chercheur de mon équipe qui s'appelle Benoît Sens,
on est intervenus à l'école Marguerite Yourcenar, qui venait d'ouvrir ses portes, pour donner des exercices de rhétorique.
Alors, il n'était pas du tout question de théorie du complot, c'est pas du tout pour ça qu'on y allait.
C'était plutôt pour développer l'esprit critique, etc.
Mais on s'est dit : on va quand même leur donner quelques outils de récits collectifs et on a voulu faire ce que faisaient les anciens, c'est-à-dire comment les anciens faisaient de l'épidictique.
Bah tout simplement, ils avaient Homère. Ils avaient l'Iliade, l'Odyssée, les mythes. Je vous ai raconté tout à l'heure celui d'Euphriné, mais on raconte Ulysse, on raconte Achille, etc.
Et ça servait de grande marmite épidictique. Et si on voulait mettre en avant des vertus, ben on chantait le courage d'Achille, etc., etc.
Donc la solution, c'est trouver le nouveau Homère ?
C'est ce qu'on s'est dit. Voilà, on s'est dit ça, Benoît et moi, mais on a été complètement naïfs parce qu'on s'est dit : c'est quoi le nouveau Homère ?
Est-ce que c'est La Guerre des étoiles ? Est-ce que c'est Harry Potter ? Est-ce que c'est, je sais pas, des fables ?
On a un petit peu essayé de tout. On a fait des sondages auprès des enfants et on s'est rendu compte que, justement, on en revient peut-être à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure, qu'il n'y avait plus de récit commun, tout simplement.
Trop de fragmentation, trop de propositions culturelles et tout le monde ne regarde pas Game of Thrones. Donc, Game of Thrones ne peut pas devenir le nouveau Homère.
Exactement. Surtout qu'à l'époque, il n'y avait pas encore Game of Thrones. Mais en fait, c'est exactement ça. Et du coup, j'en viens à la deuxième solution
qu'on a trouvée maintenant avec Lucie, donc qui est dedans, celle qui est mon assistante, avec qui
je donne cours sur les théories du complot.
Et là, on leur fait produire leur propre théorie du complot.
Ah oui.
Voilà.
Donc, vous proposez ce travail-là à vos étudiants dans le but de les vacciner ou bien dans le but de remplacer les théories du complot par un autre discours épidictique ?
Alors, c'est une très bonne question aussi, parce qu'il y a apparemment des hypothèses sur la vaccination, sur l'inoculation.
D'ailleurs, on est en discussion avec Olivier autour de ces choses-là. Et en fait, c'est pas ça. Donc c'est ni l'un ni l'autre.
Ce qu'on cherche à faire,
c'est principalement deux choses. Parce que d'abord, on leur fait produire leur propre théorie du complot, mais après un cours entier de rhétorique, où ils ont une énorme boîte à outils techniques en sachant exactement
comment faire pour que le discours conspirationniste soit le meilleur possible.
Mais là, ça n'est que la première partie du travail. La deuxième partie, qui est au moins aussi importante que la première, c'est qu'on leur demande un retour réflexif sur ce qu'ils ont fait.
C'est-à-dire, ils doivent expliquer : voilà ce qu'on a fait et pourquoi on pense que notre stratégie a été efficace, du point de vue du logos, de l'éthos et du pathos.
Et donc, ce qu'on vise, ces deux compétences, la première qui a l'air simple, mais qui à mon avis est le nerf de la guerre, c'est faire la différence entre le fictionnel et le réel.
Et comme c'est eux qui l'ont construit, ils savent bien que c'est fictionnel.
Ça a l'air con, mais voilà. Et la deuxième chose, c'est gagner en hauteur de vue en ayant un regard extrêmement technique sur les raisons de l'efficacité éventuelle d'un discours.
Oui. Donc, mais donc c'est une formation spécifique à ces étudiants. Donc ça va les faire avancer dans leur cursus, ça va les faire grandir en tant que personne, ça va, mais je reviens avec la question d'origine
: qu'est-ce qui devrait prendre la place d'Homère, finalement, le récit collectif, est-ce que c'est un objectif atteignable ?
Puisqu'on observe que les récits conspirationnistes occupent cet espace. Qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait proposer à la place ?
Est-ce que c'est imaginable ?
En fait, je crois que c'est la question qui tue, si j'ose dire.
Oui, y a pas de réponse.
Y a pas de réponse et simplement, je reste sidérée avec Benoît quand nous avons découvert, c'est-à-dire ce qu'on a eu sous les yeux, c'est que littéralement, y a plus de récit commun.
C'est ça.
Et donc ça témoigne, au plan rhétorique, de ce qui effraie tout le monde aujourd'hui, c'est qu'il y a plus de monde commun.
Alors, c'est très spontané comme réaction, mais est-ce qu'une partie de l'explication, ce ne serait pas aussi que
autrefois, y avait une chaîne de télé et qu'aujourd'hui, ma génération ont grandi avec Internet, avec une infinité de sources, une infinité de forums, de lieux de discussion,
d'endroits où on peut se former une identité, de consommer des cultures différentes, etc.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas une partie de l'explication ?
Vous avez tout à fait raison. C'est une très grande partie de l'explication et ça me permet de dire un mot de l'évolution des auditoires.
Parce qu'il est évident que si on se projette dans la Grèce antique, qui est le berceau de tout ça, les auditoires sont toujours réels.
Et ensuite, ben les poèmes, ils sont dans les têtes des gens ou ils sont dans la bouche des poètes oraux.
Mais je veux dire, tout ça est extrêmement concret ici et maintenant. Et puis ensuite, enfin bon, je vais pas refaire l'histoire des auditoires, mais rien que le fait de passer de la radio à la télé et ensuite maintenant à Internet,
bouleverse totalement la notion même d'auditoire.
Mmh.
Et en l'occurrence, je crois qu'on est la notion de bulle qui malheureusement évoque autre chose aujourd'hui. Mais
elle est, au fond, ce qui est horrible, c'est qu'avec cette pandémie, on a tout un lexique qui dit quelque chose de la situation culturelle dans laquelle se trouve le monde entier.
On est dans des bulles cognitives.
Mmh.
Et ça, c'est tout à fait réel, je pense.
On avait reçu, enfin, j'avais reçu plutôt dans l'émission, je crois que c'était en janvier, Vincent Corbitaire.
Mmh.
Donc pour parler d'individualisme. Est-ce que vous faites un lien, donc ce qu'on disait sur cet air post-vérité, le fait que le récit commun existe de moins en moins.
Est-ce que vous faites un lien entre ce constat et la montée, la suprématie de l'individualisme aujourd'hui dans nos sociétés ?
Mais je suis pas sûre qu'il y ait, enfin évidemment, j'ai pas écouté l'émission de Vincent. Donc en fait, peut-être qu'on n'est pas d'accord, je sais pas.
Moi, j'ai l'impression justement que cet individualisme, il est hérité, voilà, de l'ambiance d'après-guerre, des boomers, etc.
Et que des générations qui arrivent maintenant, il y a de plus en plus de
désir de collectivité ou de collectivisme et qui justement se manifestent de façon tout à fait désordonnée, tout à fait variée, que ce soit du véganisme au terrorisme en passant par les gilets jaunes ou
ou des ambiances New Age.
Il y a quelque chose, il y a une demande de collectivité aujourd'hui, je pense.
Oui, mais il n'y a jamais l'idée d'effacer son identité, d'effacer son individualité au profit donc du plus grand groupe auquel on appartient.
Y a toujours cette idée de : mais j'ai une spécificité, une individualité, et je suis différent de mes frères, mes sœurs, mes parents, mon entourage et ainsi de suite. Euh...
Je vois ce que vous voulez dire, mais ce que je trouve au fond, le paradoxe, qui est peut-être très très postmoderne,
on peut dire, disons, les sociétés archaïques étaient collectivistes et puis la modernité est devenue individualiste, a créé la notion d'auteur et tout.
Ben nous, on a un mélange des deux qui se traduit rhétoriquement par les formules, hashtag je suis Charlie, hashtag je suis Samuel Paty.
Oui, c'est vrai que là, pour le coup, c'est très structuré, c'est très, euh... On perd de l'individualité, tout le monde utilise la même formule.
Et surtout, ça croit dire du collectif, mais par une formule qui est, qui moi m'a toujours gênée parce que je la trouve affreusement narcissique en fait.
D'accord. C'est-à-dire ?
Qui es-tu pour dire je suis Charlie ou je suis Samuel Paty en fait ?
Mmh. Mmh. Intéressant.
Voilà. C'est-à-dire que c'est l'épithetique qu'on mérite.
Ouais.
On essaye de faire de l'épithetique, mais ça marche pas très bien en fait.
C'est ça. On va continuer après pour dire cette question, mais avant ça, je voulais vous demander, mais depuis combien de temps est-ce que vous travaillez exactement sur le conspirationnisme ?
Puisque voilà, on parle de... Dans la ligne du discours depuis que vous êtes toute petite, c'est de la fascination pour la linguistique.
Mais qu'est-ce qui vous a amené, vous, précisément, sur le champ du complotisme ?
Alors ça, c'est une histoire intéressante aussi parce qu'elle a un côté presque fortuit. À l'époque, un chercheur de mon équipe avait envie de s'occuper de ça et j'avais pas du tout envie de m'occuper de ça.
Mh.
Je trouvais que c'était ennuyeux comme sujet.
Moi, ce qui m'effraie à l'idée de regarder des vidéos de Jean-Jacques Crèvecoeur, c'est juste que c'est effrayant, c'est juste que c'est pas gai du tout.
Je suis d'accord avec vous, mais justement, à l'époque, y avait pas encore Jean-Jacques Crèvecoeur. Et y avait des choses que personnellement, je trouvais affreusement ennuyeuses comme le complot de la Lune et comme...
D'accord, oui. OK.
Et comme le 11 septembre et comme le protocole des sages.
C'était à quelle année, à peu près ? Quelle année ?
Oh ben là, on est, je dirais, en 2008, 2009.
OK.
Par là.
OK. Donc je comprends que ce soit encore assez ennuyeux à ce stade.
Et c'est ça qui est très intéressant, c'est qu'en fait, on était encore... c'est un peu comme si on était encore au XIXe siècle, si vous voulez, en 2008, 2009. On était...
le modèle, c'était le 11 septembre qui était encore assez proche. Et donc ce chercheur, avec qui j'ai édité Les rhétoriques de la conspiration après, Loïc Nicolas, a insisté parce que lui, il trouvait ça intéressant.
Et du coup, on a organisé le séminaire, on a édité,
les actes. Et donc, si vous voulez, ce qui est tout à fait troublant, c'est que j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à ça presque à reculons et à un moment,
comme on dit en français, in tempore non suspecto, c'est-à-dire vraiment...
C'est du latin, mais oui.
Oui. Puisqu'on va remettre du latin dans les écoles, voilà. Mais je veux dire, un moment qui était pas du tout l'ère du complotisme dans lequel on est aujourd'hui.
Et si vous voulez, ça m'a simplement rattrapée. Et donc maintenant, évidemment, je suis sollicitée comme Olivier et d'autres, beaucoup, beaucoup, parce que ça, c'est presque le sujet.
Mais donc, voilà.
Et alors du coup, spontanément, la question qui me vient, c'est : mais si c'était ennuyeux, boring en 2007, 2008, à quel stade est-ce que c'est devenu vraiment aussi grave ?
Qu'est-ce qui a pu déclencher ce changement ?
Ça, c'est une bonne question aussi. Je suis pas sûre d'avoir la réponse, mais simplement, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a eu un phénomène d'accélération et que l'ère des attentats en Europe...
Est-ce que ce ne serait pas aussi les réseaux sociaux ?
Eh bien entendu, y a un rôle énorme des réseaux sociaux qui est beaucoup plus important aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'était...
En 2008 ?
Oui, oui, c'est ça. Ça s'accélère furieusement. Mais je dirais qu'il y a les deux. C'est-à-dire... et vous voyez, on revient à l'idée du regard.
C'est-à-dire, bon, ben, les attentats, ça a aussi été une nouvelle ère de sidération, qui sont apparus en Europe dans ces années-là.
Et les réseaux sociaux, ben jouent aussi sur ces
ces réponses qui sont liées au regard. Ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur : mais regardez les rétroviseurs qui ont changé de couleur, dans les attentats Charlie.
Eh bien, le fait de faire passer des images en boucle produit l'effet mythe de Phriné. C'est-à-dire qu'à un moment, ça produit cet effet de persuasion ou d'intime conviction qui est irrépressible.
Et vous pouvez ensuite déconstruire, réargumenter tant que vous voulez, sur... prenez le complot de la Lune qui est tout de même vieux de 51 ans aujourd'hui.
Aussi caricatural à ce stade.
Tout à fait caricatural. Ben, vous avez vu le drapeau flotter, c'est... d'une certaine façon, c'est terminé, surtout si on vous le fait passer en boucle.
Donc, il y a cet effet d'intime conviction qui est lié au regard et au fait que les images sont sans cesse martelées, en fait.
Mh. Alors, pour être un peu plus technique.
Oui.
Parmi les concepts de la rhétorique, il y a bien sûr les trois preuves d'Aristote. Donc, pour rappel, le logos, et corrigez-moi si je dis des bêtises, hein, mais donc le logos, plutôt la raison, les arguments, les discours, les faits.
L'ethos, donc c'est plutôt l'orateur qui laisse...
C'est son caractère et ses qualités morales, la façon dont il va...
Se présente, dont il va apparaître.
Oui.
Oui, c'est ça. Et le pathos, donc là, plutôt l'émotionnel, je pense, le ressenti.
C'est tout à fait ça.
OK. Alors, si on se penche sur les contenus complotistes, par exemple, au hasard, les fameux docus comme Ceci n'est pas un complot ou bien les fameuses vidéos de Jean-Jacques Crèvecoeur, on y revient.
Qu'est-ce qui vous saute aux yeux dans, voilà, le logos, le pathos, l'ethos des personnes complotistes qui produisent ce genre de contenu ?
Voilà, je ne sais pas, les figures rhétoriques qui sont employées. Est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui vous sautent aux yeux là-dedans ?
Mais là aussi, je dirais qu'il y a une évolution assez... pour moi, y a en tout cas deux périodes et je sais pas très bien comment les choses ont évolué entre les deux.
Mais ce qui me semblait caractéristique des récits complotistes ou des discours conspirationnistes,
il y a, je dirais, une bonne dizaine d'années, quand j'ai commencé à m'y intéresser, c'est plutôt que les trois preuves, donc ethos, pathos et logos
était un petit peu, présentait des traits très mélangés et un peu incohérents.
Par exemple, prenons l'éthos, ben très souvent, vous aviez ou vous avez encore un ethos d'expert. Ça, c'est très important.
Voilà, je sais mieux que vous et je connais bien mon domaine d'expertise. Et en même temps de marginal, de quelqu'un qui n'est pas dans les institutions officielles ou qui les a quittées, bah, par courage, etc.
Et donc ça, ça me paraissait une première caractéristique. Pareil pour le logos où y avait une présentation vraiment d'esprit critique très fort, de machine à argumenter, mais en même temps, une,
justement, cette dimension de donner du sens qui était plus épidictique.
Et pareil pour le pathos. En gros, pour faire simple, ça reste tout à fait vrai. C'est rassurer en même temps qu'inquiéter.
Ce qui paraît tout à fait contradictoire.
Oui.
Je pense que le... y a une dimension,
qui est on rassure parce qu'on donne un sens collectif à ce qui se passe et en même temps, on inquiète parce qu'on sent bien qu'il y a des forces occultes, des intentions cachées, qui nous veulent peut-être du mal.
Donc ça, c'est ma première réponse, c'est qu'il y a des traits. Il y a une très grande variété et peut-être un petit peu, c'est comme un kaléidoscope.
Y a toutes sortes de traits d'éthos qui sont en principe incompatibles entre eux, mais qui, là, se présentent comme une mosaïque.
Donc ça, je dirais que c'est la première chose.
OK.
Et puis la deuxième, qui est plus récente, je dirais, c'est que... prenons « Ceci n'est pas un complot », le documentaire.
Ce qui est très troublant, c'est que ça se présente comme extrêmement argumenté. Et quand vous regardez d'un petit peu plus près, c'est que de la narration.
C'est pas vraiment de l'argumentation. Et ça, je pense que c'est nouveau. Et de mon point de vue, une hypothèse possible, c'est qu'on se passe de plus en plus
des traits de la modernité qui se présentent comme devant convaincre, argumenter rationnellement.
Et on entre dans l'ère du tout narratif, et on s'installe vraiment dans la place de l'épidictique.
Voilà, j'allais y venir.
À la place de l'épidictique, voilà.
C'est ça. Mais en quoi est-ce que faire de la narration et donner un sens aux faits sans vraiment les argumenter, sans être dans le...
Du coup, c'est, si je ne dis pas de bêtises, l'apodictique ?
L'apodictique. Disons que c'est l'argumentation, hein, voilà.
Ouais, c'est ça. Donc si on ne fait pas de l'apodictique, qu'on reste donc dans juste la narration, qu'on donne un sens aux choses, en quoi est-ce que « Ceci n'est pas un complot » n'est pas alors de l'épidictique ?
Parce que l'épidictique, c'est dans la poésie, vous avez toujours des effets qui produisent des émotions collectives positives.
D'accord.
Ça fait du bien.
OK.
C'est feel good.
En fait, l'épidictique, c'est des feel good movies.
D'accord.
Et là, ce qu'ils font, c'est des feel bad movies.
Les mêmes procédés, mais plutôt feel bad plutôt que feel good.
C'est feel bad, mais surtout, c'est pas de la poésie, parce que la poésie, elle se montre comme fictionnelle.
Oui. Ah oui, oui, c'est ça.
Alors que là, ça prend la place du réel et c'est à peu près le contraire de la poésie. C'est... par ailleurs, souvent,
enfin y a, à mes yeux, en tout cas pour ma sensibilité, c'est souvent assez moche et vulgaire et des choses comme ça.
Mais ça prend la place de la poésie tout en techniquement n'étant pas du tout de la poésie puisque ça se présente quand même comme du réel.
C'est un peu compliqué, mais—
Non, mais c'est très intéressant. Il faut suivre, mais... Donc, vous disiez premièrement un mélange entre les différentes figures d'éthos, donc à la fois le spécialiste et le marginal, ce qui est assez—
Absolument. L'expert marginal, c'est—
Assez novateur, oui.
Ce qui est assez audacieux, oui.
Mais d'ailleurs, est-ce qu'être marginal, c'est fondamentalement un plus quand on essaye de projeter une image de qui je suis, moi, qui essaye de défendre une idée ?
Si je me présente comme marginal, est-ce que j'ai un avantage ?
Oui, c'est un avantage narcissique énorme parce que vous vous présentez comme celui à qui on la fait pas. Et là, y a aussi certainement, là, c'est plutôt au plan politique, l'héritage
de l'idée qu'être citoyen libre en démocratie, c'est être du côté de la contestation et de l'insurrection.
Ça, je dirais que c'est pas un épiphénomène. On est plutôt sur le volet politique, mais y a en gros l'idée, c'est qu'être obéissant, c'est être pas libre.
Mh.
C'est une ultra-simplification de—
Oui.
...de l'idée que dans certaines situations vraiment de dictature, y a un droit à l'insurrection. Et là, si vous voulez, ben, être marginal, c'est montrer que vous incarnez l'insurrection à vous tout seul.
Ce qui est waouh pour l'éthos. C'est bien.
Oui. Donc c'est une posture, donc—
Oui.
...souvent employée en combinaison avec d'autres, hein, par exemple celle du spécialiste du je-sais-tout. Et en parallèle avec ça, vous m'expliquiez que la teneur du discours est fondamentalement...
Elle n'est pas apodictique, elle n'est pas argumentée, elle n'est pas rationnelle, mais elle est dans la narration dans le— non pas la poésie puisque c'est,
c'est plutôt feel bad, c'est plutôt, ce n'est pas de la fiction, c'est— on essaie de décrire du vrai, mais ce sont des techniques qui se rapprochent de l'épistémique.
Voilà, et donc ça, c'est une innovation donc de ce nouveau contenu conspirationniste. Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres choses, par exemple au niveau du pathos, au niveau du logos ?
Alors peut-être un point pour revenir au logos.
Oui.
C'est que j'ai pas dit qu'il y avait pas du tout d'arguments.
D'accord.
Y en a, mais simplement, ils sont connectés entre eux. Au fond, argumenter, c'est quoi ? C'est placer des raisons, des faits et des opinions dans une chaîne logico-argumentative qui va vers une conclusion.
Et là, vous avez des faits, des images, des opinions, qui sont connectées entre eux dans une trame narrative qui ne mène vers aucune conclusion. Mais séparément,
si vous faites un zoom arrière de tous ces éléments, et c'est ça aussi qui produit cet effet de persuasion, c'est que dans ces images, ces arguments et ces opinions, y a plein de choses qui sont vraies aussi.
Et donc c'est pas une, voilà, c'est pas une technique avec des ficelles monstrueuses, etc. C'est plein d'éléments de vérité qu'on vous met comme ça sous les yeux—
Ouais.
...et on vous dit : « Débrouillez-vous ». Et c'est vous, nous sommes tous des animaux interprétant. Et donc au fait—
...c'est nous qui faisons cette interprétation, vous voyez.
Mais donc plutôt une forme de vraisemblance. On prend des éléments de vérité, on les présente et puis on laisse le spectateur les interpréter.
Oui.
Et se persuader que la narration qu'il nous a présentée, c'est finalement la vérité, l'unique, inquestionnable.
Ça, je crois que c'est tout à fait important. C'est que ça produit cet effet de vérité, mais que la grande efficacité aussi
est liée au fait que c'est— au fond, c'est cet effet de dévoilement, parce que c'est vous qui l'avez interprété et ça produit vraiment cet effet de dévoilement.
Un petit quelque chose aussi à propos, je dirais, de la trame narrative et de la non-poéticité—
Mh.
...de ces feel bad movies, c'est qu'en termes de narration, justement, ça, c'est Julien Quey qui le dit, un philosophe qui s'est intéressé à ça.
Je pense qu'il a raison, ça relève plus du fantastique que du merveilleux en termes de genre. Et en fait, le merveilleux, si vous voulez, c'est du poétique totalement, non pardon, du fictionnel, pas nécessairement poétique, mais pourquoi pas,
totalement assumé.
C'est-à-dire, vous voyez, dans les contes merveilleux, ben y a des choses dont on sait bien que ça n'existe pas comme des fées avec des baguettes magiques ou des choses comme ça.
Alors que dans le fantastique, on est dans un rapport beaucoup plus clignotant au réel. C'est-à-dire, on n'est pas sûr d'avoir bien vu, on a des créatures qui sont dans l'entre-deux, comme les vampires, comme les zombies, vous voyez.
Au fond, le, on va dire, prenons la bonne fée du merveilleux, elle est clairement du côté de la fiction et donc on récupère tous les éléments éthico-esthétiques du feel good movie.
Et le vampire ou le zombie du fantastique, il— justement, on n'est jamais tout à fait sûr d'avoir bien vu ce qu'on a vu, etc.
Et ça, dans la narration conspirationniste, c'est très très fort, surtout dans les documentaires où on croit, par exemple, dans Ceci n'est pas un complot, à un moment, on voit des malades à l'hôpital en arrière-plan
et on passe assez vite dessus et le commentaire dit : « Ben cette femme, elle est maquillée, donc vous voyez bien que c'est pas—
elle devrait pas être maquillée puisqu'elle est—
Oui, ça n'a pas de sens, c'est contradictoire, ouais.
...voilà. Mais on n'est pas— on l'a vu, on l'a pas vu. Enfin, voilà, c'est un petit peu entre deux.
Oui, oui. Et donc, je reviens. Donc, si on présente ces trois preuves, éthos, pathos, logos, et qu'on remarque que donc il y a un usage des trois, qu'il y a un focus sur le,
voilà, une combinaison pour former cette narration,
cette— présenter ce sens que, voilà, ce feel bad movie, ce que je pense comprendre d'après ce que vous m'expliquez depuis tout à l'heure, c'est qu'en dehors de ces récits complotistes,
les institutions, de manière générale, nos sociétés, nos cultures, de manière générale, produisent surtout des argumentations basées sur le logos et qu'on laisse tomber le reste.
Est-ce que j'ai bien compris ?
Oui, c'est exactement ça. Et donc, ce que je crois, c'est que les producteurs et amateurs de théories du complot
nous renvoient la mauvaise conscience de la modernité qui n'a pas voulu prendre au sérieux le besoin humain naturel de donner un sens collectif à ce qui nous arrive.
Super. Autre chose à rajouter ?
Peut-être une dernière petite chose qui me paraît importante, c'est que justement, la peut-être la toute dernière étape qu'on est en train de voir et de réaliser, je dirais, c'est que beaucoup d'experts
cherchent à expliquer les théories du complot
ou les théoriciens du complot en les déconstruisant, en déconstruisant ce qui est faux ou pas valide dans leur raisonnement et à certains moments, en les disqualifiant, voire en les ridiculisant.
Et je crois que ça a un effet pervers, auquel on est en train d'assister vraiment sous les yeux, c'est que de l'autre côté, si on peut dire dans l'autre camp,
ben ils renvoient à ces experts-là leur propre miroir inversé en faisant des analyses d'experts des arguments produits par les experts et en se moquant d'eux et en les ridiculisant.
Donc on est vraiment dans un jeu—
Oui, où de part et d'autre, il y a une construction de réalité de dire : mais regardez, c'est évident que cet hurluberlu dit n'importe quoi.
Voilà.
Et finalement, il y a une espèce d'équivalence qui se crée.
Et c'est l'arroseur arrosé.
Oui.
Et je sais pas jusqu'où ça va aller, mais on est—
Donc vous me donniez l'exemple avant qu'on ait mal à l'enregistrement d'Olivier Klein, qu'on— que je disais, on l'a reçu dans ce podcast il y a un an.
Vous m'expliquiez qu'il était allé en plateau sur la RTBF pour parler donc des propos de Jean-Jacques Crèvecoeur et que dans son dernier vlog, dans son dernier récit conspirationniste, il
prend les extraits de cette émission pour justement, vous disiez l'arroseur arrosé, se moquer d'Olivier.
Est-ce que du coup, Olivier a eu tort de faire ce qu'il a fait ? Est-ce que c'est ça la conclusion ?
Alors, pour être un peu plus précise, c'est, Jean-Jacques Crèvecoeur fait une réunion en visioconférence avec certains de ses collaborateurs.
Mmm-hmm.
Et il montre pas d'extraits, mais il fait allusion.
D'accord.
En disant : j'ai eu affaire à ce chercheur de l'ULB, etc. Et ce qui m'a frappée, quels que soient les contenus, c'est que d'une certaine façon, il mimait ce qu'Olivier faisait quand on l'invitait à juger—
Il se posait en expert, finalement.
Oui, exactement. Et du coup, il y a vraiment un jeu de miroirs. Alors la question de est-ce qu'Olivier a eu tort ? Je crois pas. Il fait son—
Oui.
...son travail de psychologue spécialiste des théories du complot. Mais ce que j'essaye de dire, c'est qu'il y a un phénomène d'accélération et de mimétisme.
Vous savez, il y a la fameuse image des neurones miroirs. Enfin, c'est pas une image, il paraît qu'on a vraiment des—
Mais on a des neurones miroirs.
Voilà, bien entendu, on les a, Gallese les a découverts. Je pense qu'il y a quelque chose de cet ordre-là. Il y a un jeu de miroirs qui est en train de s'installer.
Mmm-hmm.
Parce que d'une certaine façon, Jean-Jacques Crèvecoeur faisait presque du mimétisme de ce qu'Olivier avait fait en le regardant lui.
Et du coup, comment est-ce qu'on sort de ce jeu de miroirs et de neurones miroirs, comme vous disiez ? Qu'est-ce que— Quelle est la solution pour...
Là, je pense qu'il va falloir continuer de regarder ce qui se passe.
OK. Pas encore de réponse à ce stade.
Oui, pas de réponse à ce stade parce que ça vient de sortir à peu près.
Oui oui OK.
Et il y a un nouveau phénomène par semaine qui sort pour l'instant.
Voilà, super. Peut-être un mot alors sur les formations en rhétorique, puisque vous expliquiez que c'était de plus en plus absent des cursus.
Et on évoquait le fait que vous donniez, vous participez régulièrement, donc, en tant que juré dans les concours d'éloquence de Eloquentia.
Qu'est-ce qui existe aujourd'hui pour se former en rhétorique, si on s'intéresse donc à tout ce qu'on a pu évoquer aujourd'hui ?
Ben, donc nous donnons des formations avec mon groupe, le GRAL. Et donc il y a, je dirais, de plus en plus de sollicitations de la part des acteurs sociaux, des pouvoirs publics.
Maintenant, on va avoir, j'en profite pour faire la pub, une session début septembre à laquelle tout le monde peut s'inscrire.
OK.
Les inscriptions sont ouvertes. Donc ça, nous, voilà ce qu'on fait et on fait ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure, c'est-à-dire plutôt par
l'acquisition de tous les outils et ensuite par de la production et ensuite par des
constructions d'exercices, parfois pour des besoins tout à fait spécifiques, en fonction par exemple, du type de discipline que les enseignants ont envie d'enseigner, etc.
Donc il y a une dimension spécifique. Et je dirais que nous, nous sommes une alternative à, d'une part, les ateliers philo qui sont principalement orientés vers le logos.
Et d'autre part, les concours d'éloquence qui, à mes yeux, ont la très très grande vertu émancipatrice que tout le monde...
Enfin, il y a une émulation, je dirais, qui est très très très positive dans ces concours.
Mais ça manque de fond, c'est ça que vous dites ?
Ça manque de fond et c'est hors sol.
Oui.
Encore là, la dernière fois que j'y suis allée, les gamins étaient vraiment bien et tout. Et puis les questions qui leur avaient été posées étaient formulées de telle façon qu'il y avait une négation.
Ils savaient plus comment ils étaient. Est-ce qu'ils sont pour ou contre ? Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? C'était,
voilà, je dirais que c'était inutilement compliqué par la formulation et ça n'avait pas grand-chose à voir avec des questions citoyennes que des adolescents ou des jeunes adultes peuvent se poser aujourd'hui.
Et pourtant, il y a de quoi poser des questions.
Oui. Et donc vous pensez que vos ateliers, alors, répondent à la fois à ce besoin de forme, de, que—
Ben évidemment, on est tout mieux. Ça, c'est sûr.
Oui.
Mais disons, voilà, les deux caractéristiques, c'est qu'on essaye d'être le plus réaliste possible en tenant compte des émotions et de l'éthos,
qu'on essaye d'être le plus technique possible en donnant des outils et qu'enfin, on veut être directement
concernés par la vie politique, c'est-à-dire de— là, par exemple, on,
on vient de terminer le cours de rhétorique et argumentation qui s'adresse aux étudiants d'information et communication à l'ULB.
Ben, ils doivent défendre un point de vue sur des sujets de société, du genre : faut-il rendre— interdire la vente d'alcool sur le campus ?
Faut-il— enfin des questions tout à fait précises et concrètes et pas des choses philosophico-poétiques qui leur sont pas nécessairement utiles.
Formidable. Donc, vous dites en septembre ?
Ouais.
Où ça ? Quand ça ?
Alors, c'est sur le campus de l'ULB et vous pouvez trouver tous les renseignements sur le site du GRAL.
Du GRAL, OK. Donc, on va sur le site du GRAL pour— on peut déjà s'inscrire ?
Et oui, tout à fait, les inscriptions sont ouvertes. Absolument.
C'est gratuit, c'est payant, y a des réductions ? Qu'est-ce que...
C'est payant, mais pas cher.
D'accord.
Et puis, y a des réductions, certainement—
Pour les étudiants.
Oui, voilà, voilà. Mais je dirais que ça s'adresse— enfin oui, ça s'adresse à tout le monde, mais à mon avis, le public qui se sentira le plus concerné, c'est plutôt les enseignants, les acteurs sociaux—
OK.
Voilà, ce monde-là.
Formidable. Emmanuelle Danblon, merci beaucoup.
Merci à vous. C'était un plaisir.
Mais plaisir partagé. On se retrouve dans deux semaines pour un nouvel épisode. Au revoir. Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour mon entretien avec Emmanuelle Danblon.
Comme vous vous en doutez, Emmanuelle n'est pas sur les réseaux sociaux, mais comme on le disait, vous pouvez jeter un coup d'œil sur le site du GRAL pour vous tenir au courant des formations dispensées.
J'ai mis le lien dans la description. Dans les semaines qui viennent, je suis ravi de vous dire que, sauf imprévu, je vais enfin pouvoir tenir parole et vous proposer une interview de Jean-Marc Jancovici.
Ce sera dans deux petites semaines. Donc comme d'habitude, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner au podcast, c'est gratuit. N'oubliez pas de suivre l'émission sur Twitter et Facebook pour ne rien louper.
Et surtout, surtout, n'hésitez pas à m'écrire, à me donner vos retours et vos suggestions d'invités. Je vous dis à très bientôt.
Salut !